so i saw an article in metro uk that
made me think i actually really enjoyed
reading it
it said there is nothing inappropriate
about drag queens performing for
children
that title was interesting to me it
struck my eye was written by someone who
is a drag queen who perform who does
these performances take a listen with me
i'll be honest i didn't get into drag to
entertain children a lot of my
performances are lewd suggestive or
downright filthy i love performing for
adults particularly queer adults because
it feels like we're speaking the same
language and have the same references i
love coming up with ways to startle or
surprise that audience or to make them
laugh
honest i appreciate the honesty that
said i am perfectly capable of toning
down my performances to suit all ages
i've done it before and will again
fundamentally when i perform for
children there is no real difference to
taking a kid to a musical big costumes
fun music and lots of playful
self-expression so this is someone who
clearly has decided
that they think it's appropriate to
you know perform for adults and children
and there's a modification that happens
right
this person is acknowledging i i don't
know i don't you know i'm going to make
some sort of gender you know i'm going
to step on my tongue in a second but i
don't know man woman whoever this is has
decided i don't know how they identify
but has decided i can perform
comfortably in these two settings and i
don't see a problem with it okay i can
respect that opinion i'm not saying look
again i'm not saying as an adult you
can't enjoy these things and i'm not
saying that there's not somebody capable
out there who could put on a performance
for children that's not sexualized
that looks more artistic where kids
don't really feel like they're at a
strip club
i'm not saying that's impossible i don't
know what this person's performances
look like but when i read that what i
thought was well that's just not what's
happening
99 of the time when you take your kids
to these shows
that's not what it looks like so
although this person may be admirable in
their suggestion that it's possible and
i'm not saying it's not i don't know i'd
have to see it for myself i'd have to go
see a show that was aimed at children
and see what it looks like
i don't know i can't answer that
question for you
but what it brought me to is an image
tyler i don't know if you have this one
from libs of tick tock
this is just one example
of what we're seeing unfold there's an
image and there's also an accompanying
video that goes with it i don't know if
you guys have that
so this
you see those little circles those are
kids faces
okay there's another video and that
second video by the way has a nudity
flag because i think she's wearing this
this is the video of what happened at
that event we can play that for you take
a look at what this looks like so this
this does not to me look appropriate for
children this looks like a stripper who
happens to be a drag queen putting on a
performance where there are children
there was another video that i saw where
someone had what i what looked like
strapped on i don't know if we can show
this tyler i don't know the rules on
this stuff are but looks like it's
strapped on boobs
and there's a little okay this is not to
me
and sane people out there this is not
appropriate this is this is a stripper
this is what's happening right so we
need to acknowledge
this is the reality of what's going on
now i want to say something else about
this because everybody blames the drag
queens this is not their fault
okay this is not their fault this is the
fault of parents
these drag queens can decide to do
whatever they want for all for all i
mean they can decide they can say we're
going to do a completely nude show
kids welcome they can they can make up a
poster you don't have to take your kids
that's up to you that's up to the
parents
so there's there's two problems
happening i think i think there's a lot
of people that work in drag
who
maybe would never do
shows like this and are having a problem
saying wait are these people just
transphobic what's going on they need to
take a look those people who are
responsible
and who do shows for adults
and who are artistic and talented and
maybe they're singers maybe they're
performers they need to take a look at
what is happening in front of children
in some of these shows and they need to
call it out and say that's not
appropriate wouldn't that be amazing
wouldn't that be amazing if you had drag
queens coming out and saying listen i
perform for adults but that's not
appropriate for kids you all need to
stop doing that because you're
tarnishing what i do
that would be an amazing moment and the
second tier problem is parents what's
wrong with you
what is wrong what is going on in
society that you have lost your minds
you're absorbed in some sort and need to
be accepted and now you're taking your
kids to this stuff
so conservatives out there if the
reflexes drag queens you know our bad or
drug
take a look it's parents
it's up to them how they raise their
children i mean there's all sorts of
r-rated movies out there there's all
sorts of stuff going on there's stuff
going on in regular clubs that's not
appropriate for children you every day
have to make decisions about what's
appropriate for your kid
this is no different
stop engaging
make the decision that you're not going
to be part of that if you like the short
clip you can catch another one here or
you can catch the full episode right
here